now to this FedEx is joining the push to
rename the Washington Redskins along
with investors who oppose the nicknames
racist origins the shipping giant is a
team's most high-profile sponsor paid
205 million dollars in 1999 to put its
name on the stadium where the team plays
so far the franchise has declined to
comment on FedEx's request other
sponsors like Nike are also being urged
to sever ties with the team last night
none of its official gear could be found
at Nikes online store we reached out to
Nike but have not yet heard back Yelp
eople have been saying this is
controversial racist since 1933 way back
when I was I was gonna say I went to
University of Maryland and Washington
Redskins Redskins were our team and I
used to think what's the big deal but as
you get older and you read and you
realize that a Native American friend
who said you know that's an offensive
term I went it is when I was a young
adult so you get older and you learn
things Maya Angelou used to always say
when you know better you do better and
this seems to be a perfect case for that
yeah yeah that's a good point I mean
it's definitely racist in the sense it's
referring specifically to race and I
think if people want to find out how
they think about it come up with their
own slur in their head and then put a
city name in front of it the New York
fill in the blank how do you feel about
that it should tell you something about
how you should feel about this I think
good point good point listen to Chris
Rock about that